it is the late 13th century and the
small island of Tsushima is reeling from
an assault by the mongol empire with
most of its samurai defeated and the
once serene land now ravaged by flames
all hope the Tsushima seems lost
however samurai warrior jin Sakai
survived and has vowed to retake the
island and so the stage is set for ps4
exclusive ghosts of Tsushima a stunning
open-world samurai adventure and the
first game in six years from Sly Cooper
and infamous creators sucker punch
as he roams this beautiful island under
siege jin will discover enemy camps and
strongholds filled with deadly Mongol
warriors mastery of your katana is
paramount for face-to-face
confrontations combat is swift precise
and brutal no lengthy combo strings here
rather you engage in a series of tense
one-on-one standoffs where successfully
anticipating your rivals next move ends
their life with a single flash of your
blade some enemies will try to attack
from range so it's also possible to
quickly switch to a bow and land a
faithful arrow before they do the same
to you contributing to this elegant yet
complex juggling act is the ability to
switch stances depending on the weapon
and enemy wields you can switch to a
different stance that's better equipped
at parrying a specific type of attack
however as Jean is forced to adapt in
order to fight back he will also begin
to learn new dishonorable skills as he
transitions into the titular ghost
utilizing those skills Jin can become an
unseen antagonist using stealthy
movements disruptive gadgetry and a mix
of ranged and close-quarters
assassination techniques to thin the
ranks and generally strike fear into the
mongols by lurking in the shadows and
deploying tricky items like wind chimes
and firecrackers you can lure enemies
away from their cohorts and deliver a
swift silent kill if you're detected
hope is not lost throwing down a smoke
bomb gives you the opportunity to escape
but it can also disorient a 2-fold
sufficiently to create an opening for a
backstab it's not guaranteed though
especially if you're up against tougher
armored opposition fortunately you've
also got kunai daggers up your sleeve
take out enough troops to prove your
credentials as a one-man army as some
enemies may actually drop their weapons
out of fear and pray for mercy whether
you decide to grant them that mercy is
another matter entirely
[Music]
the final crucial element in ghosts of
Tsushima is customization the items you
dressed in in aren't just for show
although they can be dyed all manner of
shades and patterns they also provide
combat and exploration advantages
collectible amamori charms can be
equipped to various slots and are
designed to enhance and complement your
play style of choice turn the tide of a
seemingly unstoppable Mongol invasion
when ghosts of Tsushima releases
exclusively on PlayStation for July 17
[Music]